Good morning John, and welcome to this
special edition of Vlogbrothers where
we discuss the basics of the United
States Tax Policy and why Warren Buffett
pays a lower tax rate
than his secretary. According to the United States government, there are basically
three ways to make money.
One: You can inherit it when someone
dies. Two: You can make it
by working. This is called ordinary
income.
Making money off YouTube ads, getting paid
to do a job, making raw materials like
yarn and then converting something worth more
than those raw materials like a cool TFiOS hat.
That's all ordinary income.
And number three
capital gains. Now before we talk about
capital gains, let's first talk about the
ordinary income tax. Some people have a
misconception here that when you reach
the new tax bracket, all of your income
lumps over into this new place, so you have
to stay below a certain tax bracket.
That's not how it works. It's actually a
significantly better system than that.
Here we have the four lowest tax brackets
for a married couple. Now if you make ten
thousand dollars a year, you pay a 10
percent tax.
You probably pay less than that because
of deductions but that's your tax rate
because the first tax bracket is zero to
seventeen thousand dollars.
Now if a married couple makes fifty thousand
dollars they've moved into the second
tax bracket, but still
their first seventeen thousand dollars
is taxed in the first tax bracket and
then the rest is taxed in the second.
This works on a scale for a hundred
thousand dollars and when I made this
graph, I had to make it extra long to fit
on five hundred thousand dollars which
includes all of the tax brackets, but even
that person the makes five hundred
thousand dollars still pays
into all of the lower tax brackets before
they get to their big high up ones.
Just wanted to clear that up.
Now, back to capital gains. Capital gains,
is money that you get
when you buy something and then you wait
and then you sell it later for more.
That's income, you've made money there.
Most capital gains are made in the stock market
though you can also do it lots other ways, real
estate being a big one. If you make more than
like thirty thousand dollars a year, your
capital gains tax
is 15 percent. It's a flat fifteen
percent for everybody.
And basically, capital gains is how really rich people make most of their money.
They invest in stuff
and then it gets more valuable and then
they sell it. Now, that's basically explaining how it
works.
Now I am going to get into how I feel about it. This is
just my opinion, but this has always seemed
really weird to me.
Money in the stock market isn't actually doing
anything. Companies don't have access to,
like, do stuff with that. It's not
being used to build cars go to Mars or
make video games or whatever.
I know that investment is important for our
economy, but so is income. Income is,
to me, it seems like it's worth more. So why
is it then that we tax people almost
invariably more
on the money that they earn by
providing actual value
like proportionate to the amount of
money they make? The idea is that
investment should be really good for the
economy and that you need to encourage
people to invest and so you should tax it
less. The problem with that is that there isn't
a lot a good data that actually supports
that claim. What kind of concerns me is that
the people who are advising the
government on these tax policy decisions
are people who make their money this way.
And maybe they, just like a lot of us do,
overvalue their particular impact on
the American endeavor. Or maybe they're
super greedy or maybe on the other hand
they're right. Maybe they're right. Maybe
lower taxes for them is better for all
of us but I can't help but feeling deep
down
that it's tremendously unfair that a
waitress at Applebee's pays a higher tax
rate than a billionaire.
Whether or not that's good policy, I'm
not sure, but it does seem like bad
ethics. But as I say, I am not an expert and
I'm completely willing to be convinced
that I'm wrong. Nerfighteria, you are not
wrong, because you kicked
John's goal in the butt right out of the
park. You kicked it in the butt outta the
park. That's a mixed sports metaphor.
A million dollars raised for Kiva before I
even got to make my first video
promoting it, but please
still keep going because one thing that
is proven economically is that micro
finance is a really great way
to help the developing world and you can
be a part of that through kiva.org.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.